I don't know how long it will last of
course in the air normally I have it in
dry ice I mean its heat capacity is
quite big
so we've come to London right away from
Nottingham to have a look at something
here at University College one of the
chemists here Andrew seller told me that
they had something really quite exciting
to show us that would go on down well in
our periodic video so let's go in and
see what it is yeah okay I've been
intrigued by mercury ever since I was a
child really ever since in National
Geographic I saw that fantastic
photograph of a minor at Almaden it was
actually sitting floating in a vat of
mercury but I kind of wondered whether
there was a way in which one could
actually show solid mercury and solid
mercury is a very surprising observation
made by James Dewar in the nineteenth
century and I thought the best thing to
do would be cast a bill and bam well a
bell and a friend of mine at King's
College mark me Dominic lent me his
wooden template and so what I decided to
do is to actually make a mold in which I
could cast a mercury bail so so I cast
myself a mold based on this in two
halves and upper half which did the
outside and then a lower half which
didn't inside and now I had a beautiful
sort of two pops which fit together with
which I get costomer Curie well then
there was the problem of how to cooler
and my first thought of course you know
typical you know let's use liquid
nitrogen that was a disaster
because the mold started to crack so at
that point I thought okay let's be
gentle and I used dry ice acetone
so I filled a bucket with dry ice
acetone put my molded let it cool down
for a good hour and then I started
pouring in the mercury head through the
top through the top through the top it
was a nerve-racking process because of
course you can't see anything well when
I was finally done disaster struck hit I
couldn't get it out of the mold
ah so in the end I had to take a chisel
to the mold and smash it apart so this
really will be one of a kind
I'm not sure that I'm going to use right
in the mo I've broken the mold
unquestionably um it's been sitting in
my -70 freezer for some time this is the
piece and we should just have a look so
here we go we'll open it and there you
can see the ice bucket which actually
contains my bell now as I said this is
minus 70 it's quite cold and here it is
you see them all and here is the
original and there it is there is my
Bell is it ending well I think you
should try it for yourself gosh it's
very heavy
it must be 2 or 3 kilos I mean it's not
the most perfect Bell in the world it
needs a little trimming around the edges
but it certainly looks like a bell
yes said does it look well that's the
interesting question and I've been I've
been sort of trying to get this perfect
the only thing is I haven't got anything
to ring it with you realise that the
inside of the Bell if you look inside it
hasn't actually got a knocker
so we're gonna have to find something
else what's that my battery
we just certainly try your biro if you
wanted to try your burrow you ready not
very exciting is it
no that is hidden together now the thing
about it is the if in fact I done my
homework right at the beginning and I
gone and looked up the elasticity the
stiffness and so on of mercury I would
have realized that it's in fact rather
softer than last and so one of the
things you don't want to do is to drop
the bill because it dents very very
easily um but yes it a slight
disappointment that it doesn't ring
loudly um but it's certainly I think a
very very beautiful object so why did
you make it was it just for fun or were
you trying to prove a real scientific
point no I think this was entirely for
fun I mean to do something sort of semi
and
possible and I think nobody's tried
before and a mercury bail I've never
heard of and so I thought you know let's
be the horse but very well that it's
great to meet an innovator in a small
way and so here we go back into the tomb
very much like like being in Egypt I
think and seeing the mummy in its
sarcophagus well thank you very much